how often do you get recognized on the
street if I come to Manhattan and walk
around for an hour I'll probably get
recognized yeah it's pretty crazy okay
well we're gonna we're gonna find this
out right now hi sir uh for a dollar do
you know who this is I don't know I'm
gonna get some musician okay okay pretty
good yes he is an artist okay he's an
artist who plays a game what game would
he play the game of Kings
nope don't know it okay hi sir do you
know who this is for a dollar negative
negative okay cool good talk though hi
ma'am do you play chess I do not okay do
you know who this is I do not okay he's
famous it's okay
okay
you know who I am for a dog oh my god
dude this is yeah of course love it okay
dude what take two dollars are you
serious yeah seriously I was about to
ask you and you just knew it yeah oh
nice nice seeing you guys thanks
appreciate yeah appreciate you man I've
always wanted to meet you okay well now
you did yeah that worked out well the
New Yorkers are so funny it's like oh
yeah what's up it's like they've just
seen you forever hey do you know who
this is for a dollar yes who is that
dude that's Levy yeah totally Rosman
that's right there you go for ten
dollars you know who I am
hi ma'am for a dollar do you know who
this is no idea okay it's okay though
good talk thank you I'm so sorry okay
thank you
he's super nice he's the nicest i surf
for a dollar do you know who this is no
okay
I am the chess.com guy but do you know
who this is
okay here's a dollar for knowing who I
was for a dollar do you know who this is
dude Jake
dude it's Jake no it's close though keep
guessing Tommy okay but by looking at
him what do you think he does what do
you think he's famous for are you show
host oh I like I like that guest oh you
oh
streamer yeah gamer yeah all those
things an Entertainer yeah all those
things
what does he entertain people with
like just looking at them what do you
think is your dance moves your comedy
your comedian oh that says all of these
things he plays chess he's the most
famous chess player yes player yeah but
I'm also a comedian yeah he's also a
comedian wait let's go get a dollar yes
you do for all the hard work what do you
think he does
by looking at him
comedian maybe okay
super comedian thank you thank you sir
for a dollar do you know who this is
no sorry what do you think he does by
looking at him you look like a magician
a magician okay I love that okay what
would he be what would it be his magic
trick like come on uh I have no clue
making it disappear yeah he wouldn't be
good at it though right not really
agreed actor actor okay yeah yeah what
type of acting
um comedy comedy really yeah not really
but I was like magician oh yeah that's
the third magician we've got so thank
you this is great it's the shirt it's
the shirt right it's got to be a shirt
okay hi for a dollar do you know who
this is
look closely it's a chess player that's
right who is he Levy you want a dollar
okay thanks man good job he got it and
I I could tell you knew you were acting
disinterested but I saw you I see the
chest in you I'm not gonna ask you again
sir it's okay appreciate you appreciate
you yep
hi sir for a dollar do you know who this
is
no yeah Lucy and I were on a scooter
once one morning and we stopped at a red
light and a lady was walking a golden
retriever it was like us and her and no
one else and she was like Gotham chess
and she like ran over to us her and her
husband like watch our videos and she
made my wife like follow her on
Instagram to send her the photo it was
my phone's upstairs
third time's the charm sir
what a beast he's a I was crushing it I
don't want to interrupt your phone call
but do you know who this is
um from Project Runway yeah yeah close
close the fashion designer obviously
hold hold on one second okay this is so
much more more important than my health
insurance
he's in great shape he uh this is a uh a
clothing designer I'm sorry I don't okay
it's okay a dollar anyway though all
right thank you he's in great shape I
can vouch okay
then where will this be broadcast so
youtube.com Project Runway oh you're
right you're right thank you
if you get to a fifth time we're out of
here fifth time we're out of here hey I
know these guys hey you guys are back
thank you
what you narrow discus I don't remember
I'm not nerodeski I'm I'm Danny wrench
oh yeah he's way better than me yeah
yeah
I'll text him who else you know who else
you follow online Hikaru you follow Levy
right yeah Magnus okay
there you go thank you yeah he came back
okay okay that's fine okay we're gonna
get out of here now thank you I told the
guy if he did five times we'd be out of
here